let's jump into this first story we have
from mediaite washington post obtains
new leaks from supreme court revealing
conservative justices are holding the
line not just that chief justice john
roberts appears to have lost control and
clarence thomas may now actually be in
in more control we don't know exactly we
don't know exactly it's only a couple
leaks the first leak was the initial
draft we took this out
mediaite says oddly the article itself
appears to include another leak which is
clearly reported to have come from
conservatives close to the court who of
course spoke on the condition of
anonymity the sources are said to have
told reporters about private
conversations between roberts and his
fellow jurists as far back as early
december they say
the leaked draft opinion is dated in
february and is almost surely obsolete
now as justices have had time to offer
dissents and revisions but as of last
week the majority of five justices to
strike row remains intact according to
three conservatives close to the court
who like others spoke on the condition
of anonymity to discuss a sensitive
matter so we don't know who these people
are clearly someone who knows what's
going on in the court presumably a clerk
they say a person close to the most
conservative members of the court said
roberts told his fellow jurors in
private conference in early december he
planned to uphold the state law and
write an opinion that left rowan casey
in place for now but the other
conservatives were more interested in an
opinion that overturned the precedence
the person said a spokesman for the
court declined to comment and messages
extended to justices were were
unreturned also according to the
washington post
they said it seems that clarence thomas
was the one who who instructed alito to
draft the majority opinion and alito has
always been in favor of uh restrictions
on abortion and opposing roe v wade so
it looks like
roberts was trying to get the
conservatives to side with upholding roe
v wade and they basically said nope nope
absolutely not so thank goodness well so
is this is this bad let me let me show
you the the the big point of the story
the hill regurgitating an npr story says
the leading theory on scotus league is a
conservative clerk and the argument is
with justice john roberts
trying to get these other conservative
justices to uphold roe v wade
a conservative clerk released the draft
opinion to force them to stick to it
because if they change their opinion now
it'll look like they were swayed by
public opinion what do you guys think i
mean if npr said it i'm going to say
probably not true
i think that if you're leaking supreme
court documents that's probably a
federal offense
yeah any exactly i mean regardless this
is a serious um this is a serious breach
of ethics i don't care who did it or why
we need to find them and we need to
punish them
yeah what do you think there seems like
part of a larger
trend toward just undermining all of our
institutions right and all of the
customs and ways of doing things that
have kind of been the glue and sinews
that have held things together over all
this time right the united states is a
country
we got all types of people here you know
from every continent on the planet every
religion every every race everything
people who believe
that all different types of ways of life
are you know the most appropriate way to
live
and you hold that together
by by a thread and that thread is those
traditions and customs and those
institutions that we use to moderate our
conversations with one another
and if we lose those things we're going
to lose everything i saw this leftist
meme post where they said republicans
are trying to burn the country down and
destroy all of its institutions
and i thought to myself that is
absolutely accurate 100 percent the
institutions that have been taken over
the left the conservatives are
absolutely intent on on on taking down
like public education the department of
education colleges so um if you think
about it in terms of what we value
as as constitutional
constitutionalists
when i hear that the constitutionalist
part of me says that's ridiculous the
left has been gutting and destroying
everything they're the ones stripping
the bill of rights and blah blah but i
don't i don't want to just be you know
overtly biased i was like well what
institutions are they talking about i'm
like oh yeah the universities yeah
definitely cultural institutions oh you
bet they've been completely taken over
so i think conservatives would love to
see the universities falter but when
we're talking about courts when we're
talking about the rule of law that's
that's absolutely not true it's the left
that's doing that in my opinion and
there's
two different layers to institutions
right there's there's harvard university
and then there's education in the united
states or there's the washington post
but then there's journalism which is an
institution right and they certainly
want to burn the washington post and
harvard you know harvard down um but i
think that
in their minds at least conservatives
want to do that so they can get back
well this is this is it's a really
interesting point
the left i think looks at the the brick
and mortar structure as the institution
and the right views the concept as the
institution
a a just court is an institution to the
left the supreme court is the
institution the court itself the
building itself well i think the left
knows that they're going to be able to
intimidate people into doing their
bidding by going after the actual
physical location so you look at the
fact that they are genuinely trying to
intimidate supreme court justices and i
think that when you look at the behavior
of the right
there is no comparison between the right
and the left in terms of how much
rioting has occurred i mean the left
it's their go too as soon as this
information got leaked we know they were
going to be threatening we knew they
were going to be threatening violence
immediately
i feel like
the locations are points of
vulnerability within the within the
institutions and like
we put so much faith and trust in in
these people at these institutions like
the president of harvard or the supreme
court justices that if they get tweaked
or or bribed or something the entire or
if they leak something the entire system
falters that in social media
administration we have a thing called
trustless systems where you don't have
to trust that someone has your back or
that someone's going to make the right
choice the system is in plain view
everyone knows what's happening it's
automatic uh and i think maybe that our
government needs trustless systems as
well
i think uh you know just going back to
my point
how the institutional uh the
establishment left and many on the left
view
the the existing structure as an
institution like the washington post is
the institution of journalism whereas
the right wants to restore the actual
institution of journalism and i think
those are different world views where
if you can understand how many on the
left or liberals or or democrats think
you'll better understand what their
arguments are that's that's kind of my
point when they said the rights try to
destroy our institutions
it's like well think what what what must
they mean harvard university not
education
they they like their their you know
archaic structures
but i think you know for us who believe
in freedom and liberty we like the idea
of education and education can come from
anywhere for me came from going online
and reading free information from
various you know professors or news
outlets
and not formal education yeah i don't
think they're trying to destroy the
system of education system but maybe the
public schooling system that dewey set
up in like the early 1900s where they're
creating these like factory workers and
and war basically soldiers are getting
people ready to raise their hand and
only speak when they're spoken to i
think a lot of people are done with that
they want school choice they want to
learn online you know phoenix university
was really groundbreaking in the early
2000s i think it was you get your degree
online
there's a basic difference between the
way conservatives and progressives
approach politics in general the way
like the
down to the level of what they think the
purpose and point of politics is right
to a progressive i mean it's built into
their name
and this is true of liberals as well
just that the purpose of politics is to
get us
somewhere that there are certain things
that either need to be fixed or improved
or achieved whatever it is and the
purpose of politics is our means of
coming together to achieve or fix or
these things
and conservatives don't see it that way
conservatives have a much more tragic
view of history they look around and say
this we're not we're not going to some
final destination in america the goal of
politics you know politics is is much
more like uh relations between family
members to conservatives that the point
of this is to make sure that we're all
still friends tomorrow that's the only
point to politics is to make sure that
we are all still friends tomorrow and
that we can come together to like deal
with things as they arise and you know
you're going to get very different
approaches to institutions when that's
the case right progressives can look at
it and say the point here is to get to
that place where this social justice aim
is achieved or whatever it is and if if
an institution seems to be slowing that
down
scorched earth i mean that institution
is in the way whereas a conservative
says no no that maintaining that
institution's credibility so that we're
not all killing each other tomorrow
instead of working through our
institutions that's the point i was
thinking about that too i was like uh
there's got to be rules that we all
agree to play by but that doesn't apply
to the progressive world view the press
of world view has been and and i'll just
throw it to the late david graber
where i started to think about these
ideas when he said that elements of the
left have embraced the fascistic tenet
there is no truth but power and you take
a look at what many on the right would
call a double standard and james lindsay
i think it's james lindsay he said there
is no double standard if it's good for
the revolution it's good if it's bad for
the revolution it's bad that's that
that's how you end up seeing
contradictory concepts like you must be
vaccinated regardless of your own body
and abortion my body my choice they then
act like conservatives are the
hypocrites when in reality they just
don't know what conservatives are
arguing whereas conservatives are
outright saying it's not your body it's
the other body address from the argument
from that point if you want to have a
conversation but they're not so you know
ultimately i think
for me i wonder what are the rules to
the to the system we're in so that i can
make sure we don't come at each other
and go nuts right and it doesn't seem
like it matters because the rules for as
you pointed out for the progressives is
to accomplish their social justice goals
social justice goals where everyone else
is kind of for the most part
conservatives but i think you know
whatever the factions really end up
being libertarian or otherwise is um
how do we live together and survive this
this catastrophe i guess yeah i
definitely think there's truth in what
you're saying the left has a much more
hegelian approach to their view of
history they see it as this this process
in the structure that is building
towards its ultimate end
and
even that i think like from a you know a
metaphysical christian worldview there's
truth in but i think conservatives as
you have said do have this more tragic
view of history it's more or less we are
teetering on the brink it's not as if we
are just guaranteed that tomorrow is
going to be better than today this could
all fall off if we try to try like
change the system in in the wrong way
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you